في اعقاب اعلان اوكرانيا تحقيق نجاحات
تكتيكيه في هجومها المضاد الذي تشنه منذ
الصيف لدحر القوات الروسيه قرر الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي النزول الى
الميدان لتفقد قواته واختار منطقه دونيسك
في شرق البلاد التي تمثل الاولويه
القتاليه في الدفاع عن ارضه حسب
تعبيره من المهم للغايه دعم جنودنا
والتحدث الى قاده الالويه وقاده الكتائب
ومن المفيد جدا
ان نسمع من اولئك الذين يخضون المعركه
مباشره ما الذي ينقصنا بالضبط وما هو كافي
بالفعل وما الذي يجب معالجته كل ما تحدث
عنه المحاربون سيكون بمثابه اسئله
للمشاركين في اجتماع الاركان وخاصه فيما
يتعلق بالحرب
الالكترونيه زياره تاتي ايضا غدات اعلان
زيلنسكي اجراء تعديل كبير في اعلى هرم
القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه في خضم الحرب
ضد روسيا وتواصل القوات الاوكرانيه
محاولات التوغل الى العمق الروسي اذ اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ورئيس بلديه موسكو
ان انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه اسقطت
طائرات المسيره اطلقتها اوكرانيا في استرا
بمنطقه موسكو وفي كالوجا كما احبط حرس
الحدود محاوله قامت بها مجموعه تخريبيه
اوكرانيه للعبور الى الاراضي الروسيه عبر
منطقه بريانسك في غرب البلاد محاولات
تكررت مرارا هذا العام جعل روسيا ترسل
مروحيات للقضاء على احدى تلك المحاولات في
منطقه بجرود في ايار مايو الماضي